*spooped  Mark*
Ohhh...
Okay.. Oh!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Please Come Over
Oh, oh hi, Holy shit, Oh my God, okay...
I- oh..
"This is the living room I don't hang out here that much" ohh okay, hi. Whooaa...
H- hey...
I just got in this game, could you please not do that? I am not okay with this... Whoa...
"This is the dining room where we eat sometimes, I prefer eating in my room though" ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*WEIRD FACE JUMPSCARE ALERT*
Oh God.. You get uncomfortably close and I don't like it..
Oh man, and the mouse sensitivity is so high!
"This is the den, where we will-" Something, watch T.V?
Can I-? Oh, look! Uh, stockfootageforfree.com (not sponsored)
Ah, do ya like that?
Whoa...
What is your name?
Oh no.. I don't even wanna give you a name, oh boy...
I, uhh..
I just fired up this game to see what it was about, I didn't know tha- that uhh, that I would already be starting
"This is the guest room, it looks different now. It use to be our toy room when we were younger."
Oh, when WE were younger.
Oh, so I know you!
Ohhh, Nick.
Radio: "Kay, we're recording"
Radio: "Trumps"
*confused Mark*
*Music begins to play from the radio*
OHHH, okay..?
Oh boy..
Whoa boy...
Oh no, oh why are you dancing, Nicholas?
*Making weird noises*
Alright, let- lets just turn that off.
Oh no, he didn't like that. [X2]
Oh no.
I broke him!
Oh boy could you get out of my way please? I have to show you the rest of the ROOOM- house!
Oh boy.
Lets see. "This is the room I share with my brother. He's not here right now-" Holy shit..
Okay, alrighty then.
Is there something in there?
What the heck is in there?
Ok. "This is my favorite show." It's GIRL... puts wheat in bunch, and... is pretty. (10/10 grammar Mark)
Okay, goodbye
"This is the bed, what do you do?"
"Make no decision."
"You make no formal choice. Whatever you do at this moment is up to you."
"Press escape to be satisfied with your decision."
*Audible inhale*
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON!
OH GOD!
"This is the bathroom, I'll give you some privacy."
Alright have fun in there.
*Sniffle* I guess..
Okay...
Oh, turn on the sink.
Wash a body part
"Maybe you feel clean, maybe you don't. Only you really know"
I don't know!?
Sit on the lid!?
Uhh, think about something?!
"You sit on the lid and think about something."
"Only you know what you're thinking about"
Oh God, turn on the water
"Nick hears from outside and is a little confused because in his experience, his guests usually don't take baths when they come over"
*Sudden realization*
OH I'M THE GUEST!
Oh I am!!
Ohhh, take a bath, okay!
Thanks, Nick!
Oh, you did give me some privacy, didn't you?
Nick!
Nick are you a little perturbed tha- Ohh boy nope, he- he's totally fine. Nice ass.
Ohh- Ah fuck!
Oh boy [X3]
Oh boy [X2]
Lie on the bed. "You lie on the bed, Nick looks at you weirdly, and looks away, kinda uncomfortably. He's unsure of what you're gonna do next"
Start a conversation
"You start a conversation with Nick on the topic of your choosing"
"He feels a variety of emotions, depending on the topic chosen"
"Nick feels surprisingly okay with you lying down too."
Thaaanks, Nick..
Thaaaaaanks...
I didn't know I was a guest over at your house.
"This is the bathroom, I'll give you some privacy" I don't need it!
Oh God no..
Nick, nooo!!
Thanks, Nick. Okay, goodbye Nick.
Can I leave? Kay..
Alright Nick. Ya know what? Maybe I should- Maybe I shouldn't be here, Nick.
Starting to think maybe I shouldn't be here.
Turn it on!
Stand in silence.
"Nick looks at it, very worried. He's so confused"
"You stand in silence with the stove on, Nick looks at the stove very worried. He has no idea what's going on and wishes it would just end"
SO DO I NICK!
SO DO I!
"You open the fridge, Nick looks at-" I didn't read that.
Oh boy, okay, you know what?
"He thinks it's a little rude to look through his fridge without asking first, but he doesn't say anything."
Okay.
Alright. I apparently can't- Oh there we go.
O- Okay, alright then.
"You turn it on, but there's nothing inside so it runs until it doesn't. Nick looks at you, wondering what you're doing, slightly worried that it might be bad to run a microwave with nothing in it."
LET IT RUN!
Oh "Nick looks at you and then at the microwave, wondering what you're doing and why you're doing it. He's very confused"
SO AM I!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING!
I am so confused!
Oh no
"This is the bathroom, I'll give you some privacy"
Oh boy...[x2]
Okay, play a movie!
Ask Nick where the tapes are
"He says he doesn't have any, which he realizes is kinda weird, and wonders himself why he doesn't own any."
Yeah that is a little weird
Turn it on but don't play a movie
"You turn on the VCR with no intention of watching a movie. Nick wonders what you're doing."
Stand in silence
"Nick wonders if you're thinking about your next move, or something else entirely. He thinks about this, and then thinks about thinking on this."
"It feels uncomfortable with the silence."
Ooookay, you know what?
I'm gonna sit
It's just that long, monotonous tone in the background, and it's horrible.
Oh hey!
Why is this on your computer, Nick?
Oh my god, okay alright then
*Sigh* I'm gonna.. Leave
This ends the game
"You leave, Nick is sad to see you go, but he hopes you'll come back again."
"Please send an email to 02.nickk@gmail.com and tell him what you did today so he can feel like he was there as well. Thank you"
*Markiplier.exe will shut down in 5...*
*Markiplier.exe will shut down in 4...*
*Markiplier.exe will shut down in 3...*
*Markiplier.exe will shut down in 2...*
*Markiplier.exe will shut down in 1...*
WHAT DID I PLAY!?!?
WHY AM I A CHANGED MAN!?
WHAT THE FUCK HAPPENED!?
*screams externally and internally*
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF THAT!?
*Groans loudly*
*More groaning*
Okay..
I gotta find out what the fuck the point of that was.
Oh my God, this is so creepy
This is so creepy
Oh man, this is so creepy
*Reads from the screen*
*Continues reading from the screen*
Oh my god.. Oh oh no, oh no!
Well maybe.. Maybe I'm being too harsh.
Maybe I'm being too harsh [X2]
Maybe I act- Maybe I need to give Nick another chance here. I kinda rushed into this. Maybe I need to like..
Go back into Nicks house. I gotta, I gotta pay Nick another visit here, because I feel like maybe I was being a little too harsh in my judgement of this.
Hello? Where are yo- OHHH hi...
"Hey thanks for coming over, what do you wanna do?"
Heh, ya know.. Maybe sit on the couch and start a conversation.
Nick you are a cool guy and I like you
Hey! Wanna watch me go to the bathroom?
I bet not.
I see that shadow behind me Nick
I see that shadow
Are you mad about something, Nick?
Oh God what the- Heyy what the fucking what the fuck is this?
Nick?
Nick!
Nick, I don't get it Nick!
How'd you get in here? I closed the door!
Gonna close the door again
Closing the door..
HEYA fucking fucking Nick, hi..
Well..
You are very close to me
Alright okay alright you know what? I'm gonna.. I'm gonna go now
Nick, I'm inside you Nick!
Oh hey... ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Hey friend..
Hey. Whoa nice head inside your head
Hey Nick, how's it going there buddy?
You know that I've always admired you
Oh boy [X4]
Okay Nick, you know what? I'm just gonna..
I'm gonna.. I'm gonna leave you to your life.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna gooo. I'm gonna get out of here
Oh boy. Oh boy, Nick
Oh boy Nick. Oh boy oh boy oh boy
*whispery Mark* I have no fucking idea what's going on here, but I feel like there's *proceedly gets louder * a deep dark secret that I don't know about that I..
I think Nick is a nice guy, but I'm not absolutely sure about that. I think Nick might...
I mean there's objectively there's nothing wrong with Nick, and I'm the weird one going into HIS HOUSE, and..
messing with his stuff!
(you okay Mark?)
But somehow I don't feel comfortable here around Nick
(Uhhh... Mark?)
But by all means Nick has been a nice guy
It's as if for some reason that monotonous tone is driving me insane Nick
Okayyyyy...
I'm  *groans*
So anyway I'm gonna leave it at that
If you guys wanna party with Nick, I'll put the game down in the description below too, where you can have a fun time all day with Nick
Who is just a cool naked guy
Anyway, thanks everybody again for watching, and as always Ill see you in the next video
Buh-bye!
*Sigh of relief and relinquish* [Hello! I'm JoshTGDG, and this is my first time doing the CC stuff... so I edit some stuff and added a few things. How's it going?]